this morning a snowstorm that will
disrupt Thanksgiving travel for millions
a slamming Colorado on its way toward
the Upper Midwest it could reach the
Northeast in time for tomorrow's big
travel day winter storm alerts stretch
across much of the country many areas
expect a foot or more of snow Barry
Petersen is in Denver at the Denver
International Airport where the forecast
calls for 15 inches Larry how's it going
well let me tell you jurika it's going
like this this is going to be the
implement of choice for a lot of people
in Denver today already eight inches of
snow here at the airport they've got 200
pieces of equipment out they just told
us flight cancellations now approaching
500 so here and for a lot of the country
it's going to be a nightmare travel day
scenes of nature's fury
are beginning to stretch for miles close
to coast oh my god of the cliff
over the cliff as drivers brace for
dangerous roads to get home for the
holiday in Salt Lake City only cars with
four-wheel drive and tires with chains
are allowed on roads emergency crews
responded to more than 50 crashes Monday
I don't like snow I'm ready for spring
shoppers from California to Michigan are
scrambling to get storm supplies
everybody's trying to get everything
done before the holiday in Denver
grocery store cashier Tamara Oliver says
they've been hit twice as hard and says
people are also shopping whether
Thanksgiving dinner why does this always
happen on a holiday Alex Renteria with
the Denver Airport says they expect
flight delays and cancellations but are
prepared for many who may be stranded
you have thousands of blankets and stop
if folks need diapers or formula or care
kits we also have those that our
information booths on a normal day the
airport would have almost two hundred
thousand passengers
Jorge pro-gay is traveling from Miami
his flight to Oregon was canceled as he
waited for another flight he skated at
Denver airports winter amenity an ice
rink
you think maybe you should have just
stayed in my 20/20 vision you know that
would have been good not just that I got
my kids living
so we're going to spend Thanksgiving
gotta get home for Thanksgiving
absolutely we've met some people who got
here six hours early for their flights
and of course they're saying everybody
should check ahead and Anthony if you
want to come to Denver I'll save this
one that's our Barry Petersen by the way
who just won a Lifetime Achievement
Award from the st. Louis Press Club
Barry congratulations the good work
there were so much in honor of your
achievements simi has to send you into
15 inches of snow I love you in the
middle of a snowstorm eggs Barry